llegará hasta ur en la provincia sureña
de nazir y a sólo 15 kilómetros del río
de flote si muy cerca del golfo pérsico
era una prioridad para el papá francisco
que quería retomar un viaje frustrado
del papa juan pablo segundo en el año
2000 la importancia es que este es el
lugar la cuna del profeta abraham y
también donde se unen las tres
religiones del libro
esta visita tiene muchos mensajes para
toda la gente alrededor del mundo
estamos juntos
este es exactamente el lugar que quería
ver el papá estas paredes que estaban un
poco reconstruidas pero que solamente
fueron encontradas en los 1900 después
de 1950 realmente es lo que se considera
la casa del profeta abraham que no
solamente tiene esa importancia para el
papá por concluir las tres religiones
del libro como las estamos viendo esta
es una reunión dedicada a ese diálogo
religioso pero también porque el profeta
abraham significa la inmigración el
exilio
somos de esta área hemos visto guerra
por más de 20 años
amamos la paz y estamos felices de que
vengan a esta región a dar su mano para
lograr la paz desde esta tierra que ha
ocurrido a diferentes es el papá escogió
hablar de comprar religión no puede usar
como instrumento de terrorismo hablo de
mosúl de lo que sufrieron y luchan ahora
por reconstruirla y también se refirió a
las minorías de los yazidíes que fueron
abusadas por el estado islámico un
discurso bastante extenso haciendo un
énfasis en como la religión y el
terrorismo no pueden ir de la mano